merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur mardi soir il est 23h30 sur
le petit parking du stade laloyaux à
étampes
en essonne département que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter ici avec quatre
autres de mes collègues
un sapeur pompiers qui intervenaient sur
un incendie de voiture a été la cible
d'un tir par arme à feu
voyant une balle lui traverser le mollet
notre collègue franck marlin maire
d'étampés présents sur les lieux au
moment de cette véritable tentative
d'homicide pourrait égrainé les actes
d'incivilité de violences urbaines
insupportables dont sa ville est victime
depuis tant d'années à l'instar de très
nombreuses villes de france
vous étiez hier sur place à ses côtés
pour témoigner de votre soutien aux
soldats du feu ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
forces de l'ordre et nous vous en
remercions monsieur le ministre je vous
sais homme d'action et de responsabilité
mais au delà du dépôt de plainte
systématique que vous avez appelez de
vos voeux hier ce qui constitue
reconnaissons le un strict minimum
comment comptez vous sortir de la
posture détruites et des discours creux
auquel votre prédécesseur nous a
malheureusement trop souvent habitué
durant cette triste première moitié du
quinquennat
vous avez déclaré hier la république est
partout chez elle assurément monsieur le
ministre
elle est partout chez elle alors comment
comptez-vous mettre hors d'état de nuire
ceux qui n'ont pas cette idée de la
france que nous avons en partage et qui
est en notre fierté nationale
en d'autres termes quand comment
comptez-vous sortir la france de la
chienlit dans laquelle elle se trouve
plongée
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur sénateurs si vous
avez raison hier soir auprès des élus de
l'essonne
je suis allé rendre visite à ceux
sapeurs-pompiers et aux camarades de sa
brigade pour leur dire évidemment
l'émotion qu'a suscitée non pas ce
simple fait divers
mais cette attaque contre la république
contre des sapeurs pompiers qui portent
l'uniforme de la solidarité est
effectivement dont l'un d'eux a été
touché par balle lors d'une intervention
au somme toute banale d'éteindre un
incendie de véhicule sur un parking
ce qui est encore plus choquant monsieur
le sénateur c'est que ce sergent chef a
connu pour la troisième fois en dix mois
une agression comme beaucoup de ses
camarades comme beaucoup de ses
camarades de l'essonne mais finalement
le sait bien de beaucoup de villes de
france
il connaît tous les jours désormais
lorsqu'il intervient alors qu'il est là
pour aider les autres et c'est sa
vocation et qu'ils soient professionnels
ou volontaires
la peur au ventre lorsqu'il est en
intervention
j'ai annoncé à la demande du premier
ministre effectivement désormais le
dépôt de plainte systématique au nom de
l'administration
en plus de ce que fera ce sapeur pompier
j'ai évoqué avec monsieur le préfet de
département et les forces de police la
façon dont on pourrait encore plus
protégés bien sûr les pompiers on en est
arrivé là monsieur le sénateur vous le
savez bien dans des interventions que
l'on pourrait qualifier de très
difficile mais je vais surtout dire que
en attaquant les pompiers en attaquant
les policiers en attaquant les gendarmes
en attaquant aussi ce conducteur de bus
qui a été tuée dans des façons
particulièrement ignoble à bayonne on
attaquant les professeurs aussi les
médecins des infirmiers ou les
infirmières on attaque la république la
république aidée par toucher l est est
attaqué
tout ne sera pas réglé en un jour la
société vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur dans certains endroits de la
république je sais de quoi je parle pour
avoir été le cas lors un territoire que
l'on peut qualifier parfois de difficile
est aujourd'hui mis en joue et bien la
volonté du gouvernement de jean castex
jean castex et du président de la
république s'est pas seulement des mots
monsieur le sénateur vous avez raison
mais c'est bien sûr des actes et je
serai partout là où on pourra faire
reculer ce qu'ils veulent
reculons tu le connais monsieur de
ministres jean avec beaucoup de
responsabilités bien sûr la république
est attaquée mais plus que la république
monsieur le ministre c'est la nation qui
est attaqué et il va bien falloir que ce
gouvernement montre ce qui n'a jamais
été montré ce qu'ils sont pour cette
nation ou ceux qui sont contre cette
nation et qui n'ont plus rien à voir
avec notre société républicaine
[Musique]